[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur
la santé oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
obama chine dans le poitou ah oui
alors oui oui oui
abba temps et c'est là il ya une semaine
je suis pas là parce qu'il est pas là
donc la wii vous dire ça va chauffer sur
tous pour vos petits cubes
est ce que vous considérez d'ailleurs
comme un bon patron ciel ah bah
franchement pas demandé leur excellent
chrono non non
non surtout demandez pas non
c'est pas parce que vous allez changer
bientôt
[Rires]
parce que halak rabineau série net 1
être exquis
explique valérie délicieux mathieu
trouver un adjectif berry
merveilleux
dit la vérité aux gros cons
[Applaudissements]
il vient de paix il ya deux périodes
mais c'était pour jeu de mot
ça revient déjà lancé des équipes sur
votre
si vous voulez
alors que delphine incroyable voilà tout
est beau et gentil benjamin
exceptionnelle alors vous n'êtes pas
obligé c'est le nombre de failles au
merveilleux fantastique n'est pas la
peine de câbles en train de réviser
publiquement
un bon temps
je souhaite à tous les salariés d'avoir
un patron comme
vous c'est parce qu'elle travaille au
bureau est bien partie d une ambiance
super c'est vrai que quand tu as eu
l'occasion de le voir une fois par an
franchement ça se passe bien je n'ai pas
souvent bon mon bureau comme ça je la
vois passer elle à bureaux ben oui bah
il bones attendait machu témoin voilà
voilà voilà à toi aussi tu es là oui
celui-là il mais joue pas souvent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nador vous savez vous pourquoi daniel et
du côté de la direction et lui aimait
écouter ce qu'on veut pas voir
bien entendu et bien voilà ne voyez pas
beaucoup à l'écart de la société
penaud antibes axes de la
l'établissement fait comme le gars hier
sur axis way de l'autre côté je pense
qu'après le magnéto qui va suivre
peut-être sortir de la société est ce
que à la création tpp vous étiez fixé de
règles normalement on peut charrier
autant qu'on veut dans tpm paix mais pas
le physique et pas les fringues jamais
sauf contretemps bas il ya eu 12 ans le
temps s'est écoulé le succès arrive
séjour
un moment tu es face à la réalité
les gens voient bien ce qui se passe on
va le voir dans un instant le succès
mais deux millions de téléspectateurs un
manque d'honnêteté
et ben cyril a décidé de dire ni comme
bouc à toutes ces règles et il a décidé
de fracasser tout le monde c'est le
retour de cyril un amour de patron
excuse moi tu peux aller vérifier les
niveaux
[Rires]
tu aimes un arbre magique assez court
parce que ça sentait pas très bien merci
merci d'être là les séries ça va alors
oui euh non c'est une merde allez on la
met sur le son lui et sur le sol un
petit pique nique
bannir les mailings oui vous avez le
grip est ce assez logique il est vendu
avec le test qu'aux vie des côtés
positifs
côté positif à la fin à cet automne le
gilet avec toi alesi on sait que jal est
une semaine chez vous comme une conne à
une hyper rigide
comment ça va toi est toujours dans le
dos port
jérôme havy la chemise claire on dirait
qu'il sort d'un tournage orgasme sur le
danube
je pense à me faire puis orchidées
plaque ci n'est pas encore dit oui elle
va se faire pousser nord qui leur dit
non en
fait c'est un lifting testiculaire non
avec la etc ça commence à ceux à se
balader lui j'ai vu à la faillite et où
lee il est arrivé ces coûts sont arrivés
deux minutes
[Rires]
il considère qu'être une bonne émission
hier j'étais éclaté au sol ouais mais je
suis en décalage horaire méchant mais je
te dise la bonne nouvelle ce soir c'est
qu'à ta maman derrière borg
[Rires]
el alj entoure avec papa joe tôt
merci je suis n'aurait appris on va
faire un tour merci tout cas très beau
déguisement d'halloween
[Applaudissements]
ce sens
mais aujourd'hui vous avez un front on
s'aime et aussi grand
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé le froid chacun là mais
vous êtes toi pas mal pas mal merci pas
mal de toi tu est l'exception qui
confirme la règle c'est au contraire une
bilan
malheureusement il y avait des vérités
excuse moi et plaisir et ça nous a
permis aux primaires citoyennes qui
feront sa marque
buick a pas d'excusés non non mais non
pas du tout puisque c'est alors si on
peut plus dire les choses c'est bon quoi
comment skype je n'ai pas but qui m'a
choqué
comment était magnifique merci tu veux
aussi tata prépare étaient prévenus des
équipes pour le dock voilà c'est là
c'est une très bonne décision pour la
chaîne
oui c'est l'impression que les
chroniqueurs ont démarré un peu l'année
du mauvais pied vous avez un peu déteint
sur eux et son canal ou quoi pourquoi ce
film c'est un jeu très bas
alors oui on adore quand tu t'endors
hier tu démarres l'année du mauvais pied
ses
[Rires]
vacances rien quelle année 87 la fête là
si taper tout le best-of de bernard
pendant les vacances oui donc j'ai
l'impression que les chroniqueurs ont
démarré l'année du mauvais pied au le
point de bonnes résolutions d'être
mignon d'être sympathique d'être gentil
vous avez bas on voit qu'un peu de cyril
en eux ils sont tous dans le clash
permanent ségur et vous qui est le récit
fidèle
[Musique]
et hypocrite mais non encore la mutuelle
non il est super mais pas menteur
[Rires]
et bien participé au ridicule mais joue
je brave et comme tous les gens qui sont
très vive le vent exactement
si vous dites ça pour elsa c'est pas
sympa
[Applaudissements]
tous les deux
beaux frères bassem bécaud arrête de
dédé le mal car on redoute qu'on met en
page 6 187
jacques attali oui est ce que vous
pouvez me citer trois interventions de
guillaume genton hier à trois noms
[Rires]
c'est une conviction je m'étais couchée
sur la salle
affichait complet non mais
c'est vrai j'ai une conviction s'il vous
plaît s'il était une grosse merde
[Applaudissements]
maladroit
jusque là c'était très bien comme
d'habitude tu disais rien au contenu
je suis content que sa réussite cette
affaire monsieur philip hook avait
disparu des cas des cadrans donc c'est
pas mal de russes lui trannoy c'est bien
foutu et moi j'en ferais vous êtes
toujours un vidéo gag
[Applaudissements]
hu
c'est pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est incroyable c'est uk voulait
demander de mettre ses couilles sur la
table c'est pas trés copie d'un
non plus avec
avec daniela côtière
cette admission et l'alarmé serré pas
avoir défroqué
merci alors cyril on va rigoler un petit
peu puisque vous savez j'ai eu un appel
d'un ami à vous non oui ça il m'a appelé
et m'a dit ça à 10 h au lycée qui il
fait c'est jean luc
reichmann oui jean luc reichmann m'a
appelé il m'a dit qu'il avait revenus
toutes vos petites bêtises le petit
sottise j'ai envie d'être dans lancement
france 3 où vivent aux sottises au
galéjade même s'est il m'a dit j'ai
réuni tout ça dans quoi dans les douze
coups de base à oui j'allais oui
salut à tous et lui a tout donné dans
les douze coups de balai et on commence
tout de suite avec baba qui visiblement
a passé ses vacances au couteau qui
adore moussa moussa on se voit deux
minutes tu fais un de quoi là alors je
t'ai déjà dit c'est 1 2 3 et 4
vois-tu cambre passé c'est pas possible
regard des mousses syrie va faire
avancer si au niveau des idées neuves en
fait ça vaut mourir on me le prendrais
mon zizi dans le formol et les gens
d'aller donner je veux tout est
certainement la science exacte on passe
tout de suite et la question clos la
gestion et à votre avis qu'est ce qu'un
ami un cube et
givet à bastia mais qui déjà un ami un
ami annabi est incubé lci c'est quoi ça
hb c'est un mec qui ont gonflé occupe
oh que les séries comme ancien et
rugueux les y as voici tout de suite
elle rit qu il les yeux mais qu'est-ce
qu'il est fort
bouillot mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa féconde de composites et
savez vous quel point commun entre baba
florian philippot il adore tous les deux
vianney gt ou voilà c'était une vraie
escroquerie moi j'arriverais venue sur
le plateau vous souvenez bas churchill
[Musique]
était là lui moi j'étais le petit et la
normale des gones ne me dis que
finalement tu es monsieur philippe ont
jamais il y aura deux passes sanitaires
à l'entrée des restes étaient là en
france qui étaient là
moi j'étais là et après le mée marceau
découvrez le même noda n'essayez pas de
les caresser dans le sens du poil pense
que ça m'a pas
de regarder les pommes data depuis non
[Rires]
et on termine avec d'autres l'étoile
mystérieuse à nous baba il sait tout
faire le saltimbanque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel danseur sec a montré à tous et je
regarde pas les émissions oui et quand
je revois les émissions il ya des têtes
qui tombent
je dis parce que voilà il ya des petits
problèmes d'organisation cette émission
on va remédier à sa merci alice
va peut-être tomber avant la fin de la
vie c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps
ciel on l'a vu dans le magnéto tout à
l'heure il ya des clashs entre les
chroniqueurs mais il ya une tension
particulièrement entre deux chroniqueurs
à ce que vous savez de qui alors bye à
la boîte franchement il ya là beaucoup
il y avait isabelle et raymond ouais
alors j'ai eu d'ailleurs bernard richet
il alors il ya gilles mathieu gilles
gillet bernard très agitée dans tous les
cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il ya eu c'est
vrai qu'il ya gilles isabelle gillet
bernard gilles gillet gillet belgique de
jj
la vraie attention ses envies de gilles
verdez et guillaume genton comme ça
j'avais même pas nous regarder le
magnéto qui va suivre et je vous
expliquerai pourquoi ensuite et en sus
il faut je vais pas l'attaquer pour une
source diaw genton à aulas voit la
preuve que gilles n'a aucun respect pour
autrui il m'a appelé antoine pendant six
mois siri parfois quand je vais aux
interpellé des gens ton parce que j'ai
peur de faire une erreur de prénom en
fait vous êtes transparent pour moi
elle a vu qu'ils vous étiez vraiment
passé qui elle a dit qu'elle était trop
mon sort un hypocrite
comment la rupture a été consommée
j'ai bien fait mais insulter
gratuitement il m'a traité de looser
d'image anton loser
c'est ringard
c'est pas très urbain non mais cyril il
est temps de tout vous avouer devant les
images si ça me permet de revoir les
tenues de gamme aux gens tout
ce qu'il ya quelque chose il ya un
esprit et un esprit de fête mais ce la
raison en fait il a récupéré votre pull
il a jusqu'au cousue
alors il est temps de tout vous avouer
sachez que vous n'êtes peut-être vous le
savez déjà d'ailleurs je suis une petite
merde comme ça je le savais
savoir les vraies infos de
ce vrai c'est pour dire des lieux
communs à toute cette tension c'est réel
c'est moi qui les causes et non j'ai
décidé cette année d'être un petit
fouteur de merde à fouteur de merde en
espagnol regardez c'est de ma faute tout
ça
[Musique]
gilou sacha ça va
dis moi tu en train de décrocher les
rushes pour pour lundi qui la fin de
semaine et
et sur les roches g guillaume qui
arrêtent pas de décharge et agents dont
les débats genre vraiment été été
fracassées [ __ ] me voir cette blonde
et tout mais vraiment sans mana
il dicte un [ __ ] de série il est tout
à fait à chaque fois que tu parles que
tu prends la parole tension hta par
l'argument juste une gueule et ça et ça
passe en fait juste voilà hangeland ce
n'est pas ce désagrément cancer émission
à dormir dans son coin il avait été
consentie il commence à parler un peu de
fatou
n'ont cesser l'escaladé genre t'as son
sahara gardien tu passais dans les loges
je disais ouais ça ça il pue le vieux
semaine et après ils commencèrent par
exemple toute façon tu vas pas ce
ringard il est lui lègue sa meuf depuis
qu'il a demandée en mariage a toujours
pas de nouvelles chaînes
c'est une merde les questions n'ont pas
besoin d'aller joueur
[Musique]
tacle pendant l'émission
j'aime pas [ __ ] la merde et j'aime la
halle et s'embrassent mugello je pas
[ __ ] la merde avait juste une première
les autres
c'est
c'est pas beau c'est barrymore voilà
c'est vraiment un fouteur de merde donc
c'est un bon garde à vous attaquer
répond jean jé aucune leçon à recevoir
de gildan est à élise lucet chez lidl
déjà
et en plus vous dire la vérité c'est que
gilles me supplie depuis des mois
d'apparaître dans mes documentaires
appareils me supplie que j'ai des
preuves les et des sms de gym envoyé en
lire les bains je vais le dire je vais
dire
c'était d'apaiser les choses
bonsoir guillaume cgil je ne sais pas si
tu as mon numéro je te contacte car
valérie m'a dit qu'il préparait un
documentaire sur jean jacques goldman
sach sache que je les rencontrais une
fois une soirée que fatou aime beaucoup
sa musique je serais heureux de
participer au tournage en spécialiste
musique par exemple très douce très fier
et on dit jamais non une petite piste je
t'embrasse gilles
c'est vrai ça avec inventé mais sms je
peux vous attaque injuste et
je suis d'accord il aime déjà fait
la preuve vraiment sur le mixage
lourdes et des impostures
cyril monsieur cyril s'il vous plaît
quand j'ai fait mon doc sur disney m'a
dit est ce que je peut apparaître de
danger ramener ma famille a dit ce n'est
pas comme ces 80 dimanche mais non c'est
parce qu'il a les mêmes oreilles de
mickey
voulais témoigner le vernis craque
gilles ça fait 8 fois tu vends à la
chaîne le même document
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr les secrets de 10 des six halls
apparu qu'à sa
gueule et les souris de disney mais
franchement ils cueillent comme nous est
grande il évolue nouvelle vie n'avait
pas oublié que mickey n'a que quatre
doigts
et je vais vous avouer quelque chose à
dire ou es la ville s'inquiète
je respecte 10 13 à 9 ben oui ils sont
super en poussins et dans le dernier la
faire paraître maxime guennic est un ami
et qui m'a dit tu sais pas pourquoi
delormeau m'a appelé pour choix dans son
documentaire comme il reprend les mêmes
images au moins il n'aura pas le même
interlocuteur et la victime de ça c'est
la chaîne et ça c'est dégueulasse parce
que j'ai la marge j'ai la marche que
vous faites et ce qui est encore plus
des
faits tout balancer
[Applaudissements]
la
prendre c'est qu'on a fait cette somme
et téléspectateurs leader ménagères donc
tu entends dire que sept cent mille
personnes est reconduit pas bouger vous
dites ça verdez sa nana mais la voilà
neuf qui sont plantés inca marche avait
autant de conneries ils ont tout marché
attendant si c'était si internet est ce
que déjà ce sms envoyé à guilloton est
vrai oui les faut pas montrer le moi et
toi est faite attention les enfants
encore
plus allusif donne moi ça faux et usage
de faux you may ouais j'ai la prison la
mise en examen demain
quoi
non mais attendez
[Musique]
regardez à quoi sa tion et celle à
présent que c'est vrai regardez la
réponse est avant tout le rôle de sa
loge il malheureusement tous les
intervenants sont bookés je te rappel si
une opportunité se présente d'accord
merci pour ce qu'il soit possible de mu
ne peut intervenir à titre gracieux
j'étais coordonner les semeurs venir
vers toi j'étais sur gillet d'une merde
non c'est pas pareil c'est pas de régime
je vais regarder le nuit rothschild je
connais par coeur à la lueur cyril 520
région c'est pas qu'il verrait
on a triché pas numéro de gil blas à
52 c'est plus important
encore une fois guillaume genton vous
avez encore fait c'est de la
manipulation
c'est très grave je confisque déjà ça
je le mets dans mon ski
[Applaudissements]
j'espère juste que personne ne m'a
appelé mais si sa libre sans
être
géniaux de la he arc et le double du
prix
je vous le dis voilà comme ça ça c'est
fait camionnage
et tellement envie d'appeler guillaume
[Rires]
a battu va savoir ce qu'on vit basile
ça sonne pas m et chérif yoplait dont
jean bernège vous avez vu je vous ai
encore mais sans mener cette enquête a
bien je vous encore sauvé maxi série
c'est un guy genton c'est horrible
matthieu delormeau c'est horrible tous
les deux je vous enlève tous les
documentaires jusqu'à nouvel ordre la
lah sur la chaîne s'est vite sur le
groupe pierre et plus et surtout les
gonds français d'audiovisuel et même si
bien
gilles verdez heureux très heureux merci
cyril est ce que vous avez quelque chose
à leur répondre mais je peux vous avouer
quelque chose parce que ce que vous avez
dit que vous disiez tout des maxis et
s'annonce est alors temps que c'était au
détriment de la sienne je voulais pas
l'avouer mais le problème c'est que
mathieu voulait monter une arnaque à
votre détriment
vous appelez la co présidents je dois
dire et je dois dire que guillaume a
résisté il a repoussé mathieu
mais non
j'ai fait ça fait maintenant alors
c'est bon moi je peux décrocher
[Applaudissements]
mais là
passé en gare de biot
[Applaudissements]
autre adage que la balance au contact
cet ensemble
à
chercher dans ghost arnaque dans les
documentaires tout est une affaire et
alors que la marge qu'on réalise vous le
savez très bien mais voilà ouais ouais
donc oui et non mathieu est allé voir
guillaume en loge j'étais là cachées et
il lui a dit de lui ajoute guillaume il
faut absolument que tu monte les marches
que tu fais donc mais non chez les olé
alors oui
c'est dommage je peux pas quand je fais
des docks c'est avec cyril et mathieu
lui a dit mais moins jarnac c'est la
somme de jeu membres le bjp en actes sur
la somme que je demande et il a obligés
à guillaume qui a refusé il l'a obligé
on ne comprend rien
découvrir les chiffres vous arnaquer sur
les marches qui réalise ces travaux un
comorien santé des élèves avec quelqu'un
c'est vrai